hey welcome back to another episode of
riffing with Griffin this is a special
special episode and as usual I don't
have a theme song and we have another
great artist to send in a theme song and
all this information will be you know on
the video but this one's great but
before you do that let me introduce to
let's do a theme song now no I'm gonna
introduce you guys first didn't think
think think no it's not gonna be like
racist Asian I just want to say these
are the top top five Lee's right here
this is two of the top five leaves
number two and number five of my
favorite leaves of all time whoa whoa
whoa
how many of these do you know Stan Lee
is number one but you know yeah I don't
know yeah yeah he died I know so Stan
Lee is number one Steve is number two
yeah Bruce Lee is number three yeah and
then that there's a buddy of mine named
Peter Peter two of my top five leaves in
the house right now but this is my
another theme song that this might be
the new theme song y'all oh [ __ ] I
[ __ ] it up here we go
somebody made this for me
Who am I
[Music]
this guy's gonna see this thank you
be even Bobby Bobby get a studio quality
in this anyways welcome to wear from
with Griffin and I have from the Stevie
we be show blow your nose birth we got
bird flu in the house right now yes our
a/c leaves from Steve Wiebe show and
Bobby Lee from tiger belly two of my
best friends in the whole wide world and
I wanted to have them all together they
actually are brothers this is not like a
Michael Jackson LaToya Jackson thing
where they're never in the room at the
same time yes this is Union I justify 10
years that's true that yeah like three
is the reunion yeah Bob Bob brought you
in we just started it all present of
elders and we haven't played video games
together since yeah it's been how many
try to do the Star Wars thing we try
good yeah but Star Wars is boring it's
so boring it's fun though
it's fun but it's the same thing over
and over yeah had that same like destiny
like yeah yeah I don't mind doing the
same [ __ ] over and over again when I
play destiny but those nights I was
playing destiny were Raiders the
greatest nights and of video game
history
do you remember quadrant yeah some
Quadron was the best yeah I just just
yelling nights yes we you're like you're
like hissy fits why we say [ __ ] you Eric
I'm leaving you leave no no and there
you go
bye like a [ __ ] like a [ __ ] we've
got idea
high stress trust level high stress yeah
but here's this is go bio-memory lay my
favorite times my favorite days man the
first time I ever met you is my favorite
[ __ ] ever it's like I go to Bobby's
place and FIFA we played FIFA and you
really thought you were gonna beat me
that was the fun thing [ __ ] yeah
I thought I got you one but the fun
thing was when you to play
we don't play no more to play no more
from 2007 know one time I was at his
house and I won mm-hmm and he I look at
him he looks at me and he just goes oh
no no no I know I didn't punch it like
that I punched you like now yeah pop I
would rap like as hard as he could like
yeah but you know what though I get it
is your a sore winner
you're like a whoa he does cheap stuff
yeah he's doing boy what do you mean
well this is going back to knockout
Kings 2002 oh you want to get there you
want to go there I was like we went all
12 rounds and there's a move where you
can hit him in the nuts
uh-huh hmm and so when you hit say they
warn't the ref Warren to you but the
boxer bends down like then you could
uppercut like cheap uppercut them uh-huh
well by the way though this is part of
the game you it's something that you can
do in the game right and you also risk
being fouled out it's a fritz frowned
it's not fun about you can do it it's
it's a cheap so what I'm saying in FIFA
can you slide tackle
yeah it's frowned upon yeah but you do
it cuz there's a button that you thought
it would be annoying if you were playing
someone they was constantly slide
tackling oh this is we went all 12
rounds okay so it was like back and
forth back and forth you know I'm saying
so it was already like the intensity
level was at its peak Yeah right it
could have gone either way
don't fight the boxing match okay so
he's in order for him to win he did this
move by the way have you did you already
warned him have you guys already had
like
existing rules like we don't do this
move it should be known so it never says
unspoken in the Li house is unspoken you
don't do this move we're not good at so
anyway what happened was I did that I
won right right because I had I didn't
do it all 12 rounds so it was just I
wasn't my it was my first warning it was
your knockout move right I did it
but can I tell you what he did has to do
with video games knockout Kings okay
what did he do so the night the night so
I had a test i was testing for madman TV
oh my right so i'm the next morning i
have to go to fox you [ __ ] [ __ ]
let me kill the story for her okay so um
i have to be at fox at like 9:00 in the
morning and i know that i'm auditioning
it's between me and taran killam oh god
you shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up so
we're playing now called camera and i
win okay it's not that mood I just win
and my brother goes oh yeah he goes to
the kitchen and we're living together
uh-huh
he takes two knives not butter knives
rough days like steak knife to steak
knives right and he starts no no I had
him behind my back yeah well I know I
couldn't but I saw you take them what
were you that was that move they don't
know is there part of you that Lily
would you have woken up and he would be
a knife in his eye and one in his gut
and you would have been like you didn't
know what happened do you black out like
that hey does you know I'm a lot
different now okay wow I'm doing no real
talk yeah I want to make an amends I'm
so you already apologized for yeah I
have another rate okay I got
okay so he lunge it right no no no I'm
doing it back no Steve I don't we
already did that okay yeah but he did
not you had to show the knives we're
living in a mansion
I had a rehearse like reverse katana
grips on I was doing it we do a Tekken
yeah yeah yeah yeah but I was but then I
was like I saw you take though I know
you have them I don't care what grip you
have okay let me ask you in this moment
right now in this moment as brothers
yeah all right when that is happening
what is going through your head like are
you gonna kill your brothers and what
are you ragging Reds no okay so your red
song is red yeah that's your yah yah yah
and what are you thinking at this point
I'm basically Steve I could attest to
find four hours from now it's my dream
you know that was my angle yeah get him
to calm down just a select few times it
throughout our lifespan what where I
could sense the vulnerability and he's
like you know like yeah just like dude
why don't I yeah like I know he's raised
a this when you have those tender
moments on the ABC show are you
channeling this moment but my hypothesis
is that happened for a reason because it
it drove him to get the MADtv he's
taking card it had nothing to do with
that this is something that's why I
could have had a better audition I drove
he would have barely man it would have
been on for 14 years instead of 30 go
ahead okay did I ever tell tell you what
he did for my birthday no all right so
on one day he goes Bob I got your
present she comes over and like what is
it and he goes like this it's two
tickets to a movie
mm-hmm all right right for the master
you know Philip Seymour Hoffman
great movie so I go alright what's the
master today at 6:30 so we we go to the
ArcLight and it's like opening night or
whatever some packed right well I think
what it was it was the oh no how
sometimes the Ark like we'll have we get
the movie two weeks before just as a
test run or whatever so it was just like
the only theater that was playing it
uh-huh
so we sit in this crowded theater and
I'm next to my brother
so I'm sitting here he is exactly like
this but next to my brother yeah you're
next to my brother is probably a 50 year
old lady no she was no we don't know
it's dark okay I think she was 15 okay
and her husband and they're just sitting
there
and I was trying to enjoy the movie as
well I know so in the beginning I never
saw the movie by the way right you
haven't seen it no because oh right yeah
till this day I've never seen the movie
because I've tried
I bought the movie but every time I
watch the movie I think of this I turn
it off you already did it okay you
already apologized for it so does the
public commands oh yeah so we're sitting
there and the movie starts and there is
the first 20 minutes of movie Joaquin
Phoenix is like you know doing crazy
things like running through a field
drunk acting maniacally you know in the
movie and my brother and I we've always
laughed at awkward awkward parts where
somebody's acting maniacally because we
relate to recovering are all I already
see where this is going right so I'm
enjoying the movie okay believe you say
this so normal people don't laugh at
this moment in the movie no no gosh I am
okay I mean I also say this oh did I
know what you're doing I know what
you're doing I know what you're doing
sorry I know what you're doing and
you're wrong I know what you're doing
and you're wrong you're tryna you're
trying to tell us that there's certain
ways to behave in a movie theater
response I'm saying I'm enjoying his
performance yeah I am too
okay so now I'm gonna give you an
example before you guys finish your
storm I'm gonna step in to give you an
example
all right I went to go see Karate Kid
with a with a friend of mine okay
like in the 80s the new Karate call the
one with Jaden Smith right I enjoyed it
there's a moment in this movie I like it
is it there's a moment in this movie
where Jackie Chan is in the car he just
crushed the car yeah and he has this
moment about why he's doing this
yeah because his family got in a car
crash and he thinks it's his car every
year yeah the best acting of his career
okay I was just like in tears you know
yeah
person next to me this guy was like this
is stupid
yeah I was like you're dead to me again
if you don't feel a moment that I'm
feeling in the movie like I'm feeling
something and you're belittling it that
makes me feel something
so you're on our side about it what I'm
saying is you might have had a reaction
that was not like no in the vein of what
everybody else is having no that guy
reacted to your reaction no no he was he
was talking [ __ ] about like this was
down like I don't get why he was crying
okay but that would get that though is
that's not what we were doing okay what
we were doing is somebody wrote that
scene right uh-huh
somebody thought that that was you know
mean fun right back that could be
understood as calm as some sort of okay
right yeah I can't do comedy you guys
had a reaction that wasn't so the people
next to you did what
so we were laughing and a lady next to
him right goes she you know that little
hand let rest the let though arm rust
she caps it no she goes like this she
went like this
she went yeah like that's why I'm like
this
yeah like that to him right now
check this out he got he had steak man
oh yeah now when she will now when she
what I did right I what
it was a slow boat yeah uh-huh
yes building brother yeah yeah I'm let
you know it was building yeah why do you
turn into a WWF wrestler no my eyes
crossed Yeah right and I just start like
what did you have to do you know I know
I know I like to the lady a code you
don't know what you're [ __ ] with
Bruce Banner is like hey little boy all
right I get it yeah I get it
be good you know I guess you could read
that you know from to that little boy
but so anyway my brain thought so now
I'm watching the movie and I'm sweating
now and now my brother is purposely
laughing oh you were doing that I don't
remember you get her and do it again
right right by the way I guess I don't
remember yeah yeah I get it your eye
right okay then my brother does this
this is a great one huh my brother
laughs and then he looks at her and he
goes pepper on the [ __ ] thing hey an
eye for an eye a tooth for a tooth
yeah but she didn't do it I prefer to as
people yeah okay all I did was I did the
same thing that she did to me I went and
they're here now that's all I kept no
that's a no that's not all you get and
then you Moto e time Steve yeah this is
the lady right
this is what he does huh he goes no you
know I didn't exactly know he went like
this you did one I did two arms and I'm
I'm basically creating space his elbow
elbow no no no I'm doing this okay I was
there I know I'm doing but you said
one elbow I'm like okay well here's the
thing and at that moment right now there
was already tension so any move like
that would come across as aggressive so
I so then what did she do at that point
so there her husband Jesus is now
looking uh huh
excuse yeah what right I grabbed him by
the hair no no no no I look at the
husband yeah yeah yeah okay so now
you're ready to go I'm getting my Poway
wrestling's down like I'm ready I'm
ready
yeah and I'm like we're in the middle in
the middle of the San Diego magazine
fireman's carry
so I go we're leaving I grab his hair
yeah and I drag them through like over
people okay right I drag them right we
go outside right and I have my ticket
uh-huh I go thanks for the happy bird
what is the worst birthday what if you
when it came out all your friends are in
the lobby oh that was all just like
Miriam everybody can I say this too is
that I have so many stories like that in
your adulthood but when you guys were
growing up just like a thing what he
threw me through a window growing up you
know so we're wrestling in my parents
bedroom
eighth grade oh girl you can't be trying
out confession no your wrestling team
you were on the wrestling team I was not
in the resin team you know you were at
your your you wrestle to my man I know
but I watch the tires just stop stop
stop stop but you have wrestling skills
nothing I remember I just listen I
remember I was sober I got sober when I
was 17 when I got sober I quit the
wrestling team so I know I wasn't on the
wrestling team at the time you I was a
senior you were were you drunk
he was basically training me we're doing
trainings because I want him to be a
champion
so we wouldn't my parents had this
gigantic space like it was another it
was like a cube of car in front of their
of their bed yeah so we were going
wrestling wrestling and yeah we're your
parents yeah yeah and we're restroom
with a nanny got to the point where he
start head-butting me no I didn't start
hide bunny yeah that started it yeah you
know maybe he doesn't have control of
his huge head you know what I mean his
head is bigger than it should be
so he probably didn't have you know
you're the mr. Potato Head
I've seen memes okay I've seen names of
you this is spuds happening right now
so um eventually I can see him rage out
in there but did you know about him and
you know if you know what we do when
we're standing right we're you know
we're your head touched his head know
where our heads are like this and we're
wrestling and I'm like rubbing it like
you know Indian you know like an Indian
rub with my head on his head so your
head is touching his head yeah but he's
touching mine as well it's mutual but
who instigated ahead touch it doesn't
know we were doing that you know we're
locking up so my brother just goes and
he threw me I shocked him you shocked me
I didn't throw he shut me and I was out
the wind and then he flew out the window
shards of glass on my body I was out the
window like this is you do your own
stuff they asked you said this is what
you want it for riffin with you yeah you
know we want the world to know yeah what
you're like he's not like that anymore
which is to his credit he's not like
that anyway I'm doing they're doing
great I'm going to meetings you look
guys you ever look back on and be like
oh my god I can't believe I was I was an
unlikeable hothead kid who know you
probably a likeable hothead kid that's
probably what this Stephen work in the
mills looking at was looking at that
camera yeah and I went just look in the
camera he's 44 years old look at him
look 26 yeah
yeah Thank You Bobby looks like your
father I'm learning man you know I'm
going to meetings I have my therapy ever
you know I go to therapy every Tuesday
and you know where like I'm working out
these these things you know good therapy
for you so I'm sorry man you know I was
I was a troubled kid you know and I mean
the story goes deeper you know as far as
wrestling and you were me I was ranked
second in the state I chose yeah no you
were second in the state is because when
you read them when we're playing video
game I was ranked second I chose to
bring it up
I'll show you want to go okay ranked
second I know but in your red zones you
you you mention it I don't know why I
apologize for that
that's so childish yeah we ever gonna
play destiny
kalila yeah what happened we had such a
good night because imagine I get it no
you don't know no I already know because
what the yelling that we do and then
like I can't even when I'm not even
yelling I can't play video games around
my girlfriend when I'm just being like
damn it
it's 6:30 in the morning all right on a
Wednesday morning Wednesday we haven't
slept haven't slept we're trying to be
quadrant yeah you know in prison of
elders
yes destiny mm-hmm I'm screaming right
rocket-launcher out running around I
love a lot of those in the next one
hearing me right just in tears because
you can't sleep because I'm screaming
you know and so I made a deal with her I
said I'm looking for a house we've it
we've looked at he'll be 80 houses right
and once I get a house and trust me when
I go in the house that's the first thing
in my head is where do I play where do I
play destiny yeah Oh like your mancave
yeah and it's like
I mean and then like but then there were
some houses there have been like other
there's like other how like a guest
house mm-hmm
so that's what I'm looking for a
complete area you need a bunker man like
a like a riot you know I mean in case
the zombie apocalypse breaks and you
don't you don't have to stop you know
there's a red bull bar and there's but
you know have you have you have you look
for houses I know so hard I know because
the thing is is that number one I did I
was looking I what I did everyone I know
what you're saying just look expensive
yeah especially right now it's like it's
like you you what you can buy in like my
parents house in Arizona when Gilbert is
in Gilbert which is in LA that would
cost 1.3 million dollars mmm-hmm it's
ridiculous
yeah right so it's like it's very
difficult to find what you need
well you trying to figure out do you
want space or do you want location he
needs it to look a certain way is the
thing yeah he wants gotta be did exactly
how he wants he's good it's gonna be
like the lair of a because if you're
gonna buy a house that's two million
dollars you know meet you in your head
you're like how am I gonna pay it that's
the first thing number two you're like
oh this is the last thing I buy Yeah
Yeah right
that's a biggest purchase of your life
daliyah's like I just bought three
houses yeah yeah I'm not there like I
may never get there yeah he's killing to
you right but it's like for me it's like
I don't you know it's not like I'm not
paycheck to paycheck
I have savings yeah but it's like it'll
put it down but this is a big yeah big
thing a big thing yeah yeah but the
thing about Los Angeles area though is
that like I'm saying you you're trying
to determine like there's people from
other places from rural places are from
places that you know there you have big
yard they used to that kind of [ __ ] so
they come and they're like oh I want a
yard and all this stuff and I think when
you're in LA you're like no I want to
live near this or near that it's about
that stuff not about like I don't [ __ ]
my phone also I always Google whenever
I'm like I had a house I'm looking at
how far is this house from the comedies
right that kind of you know or how far
is it from LAX
anywhere easy airport right that has to
be coming to play too but people from
other places they don't care about that
stuff they're looking at like a hundred
we saw this weekend hey go ahead we're
in the backyard it was perfect when was
it at it was over at Studio City it was
perfect and he got like the only thing
he didn't know I had animals the only
thing is there's these three hawks oh
they'll pick off the cats as a side note
yeah oh this is Hawks this is England
hawks and I go yeah you guys ending
there they're known to eat cats or
attack them well there goes this house
yeah and I go leave that out out real
estate guy yeah or anyone coming here no
you know he'll know they have to just
wonder what have you bought this house
yeah and a wine I was like I don't I
don't know no you oh wow
no then you go to the neighbors right
there's a lot yeah this is no there's no
that you know what's gonna happen as you
move in yeah you getting all settled
your cat is walking around when your
neighbors come talks on the door and
goes yo do you know about the Hawks
right Oh your house is called the hawk
house you don't know that yeah it's the
hot that's where all the hops in LA hang
out that's equivalent to finding out
somebody died in here I I always ask
that some ghosts or some clothes that
right if there was a death do that in
Silver Lake
I found a Japanese house with an
elevator it was the best house this
would you you want you right that's the
one I want it but then I asked did the
owners die here they both died yet
within a week of each other
what's in the house and I go it's not
the house I pass they died in the house
yeah they died in the house yeah old
white people forget it that's the last
thing I need is a walking down a dark
hole why people even if they were alive
it would be scary right they don't even
go yeah if they're in your house yeah
even if it was an Asian person I'm like
what are you doing here Ching Yeah right
but like a white dude in my house an old
one
oh my
what's the most recent another thing we
have in common we love scary movies you
know it's so funny because um I've told
you to watch hereditary I just haven't
had the I know but I thought I saw the
nun it's not a plane
I saw the nun again no I thought it was
I know I'm gonna say it but you saw it
though right I did see it your time to
watch that piece of [ __ ] no I it's a
piece of [ __ ] they weren't out at the
same time Yeah right if it was up way
before that no yeah I was with people
that wanted to see it or not okay
no no what I'm saying to you is this I'm
gonna watch the movie
it's just that I'm about to go see my
mom in Spain I'm sure it's on the plane
because I've seen it on the plane so
many times that would they have it I
just don't want to watch a scary movie
on a plane I feel like Italy you're
gonna hate it because it's not the
conjuring it's not the ones that you
like you know you like jump-scares no
this is more psychological this is
that's a slow burn but I did like a
really slow burn the witch same
producers okay Suspiria do you I want to
see that happen to you that was amazing
wait wait is there subtitle do you need
some times in this now because that
which was I know and you do the sound
and you know I'm gone for peace I'm done
listening to a car is born he called me
after a star is born
alright crying dude like wait wait I saw
that I'm with you dude sad for no reason
Eliot it's character with zippers I mean
that remind me of Bob Lazar - oh yes of
course you saw - I did you can't have
alcoholic in my life they know their
relationship just but I'm saying like
just like anything you know what scene
yeah yeah yeah yeah in the car oh yeah I
thought of him
I totally get it you get it now yes
I broke down you're a monster he's like
you it wasn't oh yeah yeah but doesn't
that remind you yeah all right now I see
it the way I look up yeah yeah yeah
how good was the acting in that case
great but it was dude it was a good
movie damn but there was you have to
watch it you haven't even seen it no he
has he refuses no you have to watch it
and then not like it and then get mad at
him this is what it is yeah anything
that I say it stems from childhood
anything that I say is good he really in
his amazing no no that's not what it is
is that when they're in Silverlake what
did you say I read about you're not uses
white watch uh-huh
when I was in Silverlight uh-huh I came
home one time I think the road or
something we were living together and I
said he goes Bob what movie was a joke
yeah but what movie what movie was it I
just movie called Red Planet
it was Red Planet now kill Yeah Yeah
right so I'm I'm know so I'm have chips
I have a little blanket I'm could you
try to the closet yeah at what point in
the movie did you go ninety percent in
the movie I can hear I'm like this and
my brothers giggling cuz you got yeah in
my head I'm like there better be a
switch at the end yeah it's better blow
my [ __ ]
so bad yeah yes so I was giggling so an
hour a half in I turn around yeah yeah
yeah but then how do you
oh yeah how do you trust with movie I
[Laughter]
understand yeah you [ __ ] it up did you
not our trust
yeah the trust thing yeah yeah but you
know what you're right you don't have to
watch any of them you know no no you
watch what you he does have different
things that he it's okay
and he'll so it's he's so stubborn he
won't watch things that like ever like
did you see any of the Deadpool movie I
am gonna watch dead did you like oh
they're funny you know there's no good
punk rock type attitude no no it's not
that
it's I have a weird thing where if I
don't want you like opening week you
don't want to watch there has to be a
window you don't I'm saying like I would
never see a stars born if it's like two
years from now I'm like I don't want to
watch it like this I want to watch it
yeah you know so it's just weird
yeah it's a weird thing okay well then
don't watch it but I want to watch
what's the unbreakable what's that thing
oh the new Shyamalan movie Shyamalan
what's that one called miss mr. glass
glass Wow I'm down for that
I'm waiting for that well come on did
you see the other one yeah it was okay
yes okay
I put the ending was amazing I realize
it was tight on break I loved
unbreakable do I go
yeah yeah it wasn't like a like a great
moment but it was one of those like oh
good for you yeah yeah yeah yeah and
also Shyamalan let me talk about
Shyamalan all right he had some really
bad years we had some good years
no but bro okay let's let's go let's go
airbender are you kidding me at that
were a couple let's start from the
beginning oh good one let's start from
the beginning and let's go through his
movie yes let's rank them okay okay okay
Sixth Sense was a masterpiece out of ten
puppy in 99.5 Master P it was really
good really good nobody gives me about
that movie is in the end I thought oh
this kid was alone the whole time oh
yeah also introduced us with great
actress twenty collect yeah so the
second one is unbreakable you think
that's the second best movie of his no
I'm just going through the movie
Oh order and that's rank them in order
yeah I'll shave you no no I know it in
order I believe I think I know great
okay no so the second one is unbreakable
breakable
what is this best damn breaker 1-9 yeah
I would say 98.5 knives really great
really really summer Sam Jack's best
okay yeah and now the third one is a
controversial one science signs signs I
give it a nine nine Wow
and here's where we sank you for
watching river yeah no no dude I can't I
can't my brother now my brother I saw it
together
alright listen listen I'm gonna defend
it go ahead okay um this would be like
if we're exploring a planet and we find
an acid planet and we're like let's go
there hmm
no the earth is made of 70% water but
can I just say this though this is the
most ridiculous science if it's an alien
race that's looking for resources right
not only just an alien race that can
just let me connect they can travel
anywhere right okay so they're going
through planet to planet that are
that have the read you can like it
they're probably looking for m-class
planets right okay all right so they
find a planet I got big a lot of water
right it can kill us I know but we've a
water balloon can kill yeah we this is
we've traveled three million light-years
and this is the only m-class planet
we've run into yeah but for they have
all we have the resources that we need
in the middle of the plan with their
technology it's like going from Culver
City to Burbank you know I mean it's not
like right so just hear me out okay okay
so it's like the that's how I get
through that little glitch okay so your
summer I get what you're saying
all right and then here's another glitch
that I have in my head huh there's
several problems I have with the movie
that's why it's not a nine I know I'm
gonna tell you it's an AI and I contend
no it's not how much it's a 7 mm yeah I
guess okay but at that point I was
getting a little bit like oh what's
going on here's another thing is is that
they can't open up doors right yeah
that's another glitch yeah or think
that's like what the [ __ ] right does it
make any sense right here's a there's
another one all the third thing this is
a more subtle of subtler thing that
people haven't really talked about but I
noticed it why is that there they
barricaded the door to the house right
when were they're like making that
dinner yeah the windows and they like
imagine Kirby would Kirby be out there
your dog should be out there that's the
first thing I think of is my [ __ ] dog
right even if my dog's had like
something that does a disease what they
were like acting crazy I would still put
them in a room yeah give them a chance
all right that's the third thing but
here's why I'll tell you why a 9 I'm
gonna tell you why okay continue why is
it out of 15 no out of 10 oh I'm gonna
tell you why
okay and this is gonna sound personal
and dumb okay and I'm not gonna speak
for yourself okay but here's it I I'm
sober you know that right yeah and so
I'm rising but yeah yeah so I believe
this is what I believe in my life and
this is a dumb just say I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say you're stupid I believe
that everything happens for a reason
right
I believe there's a spiritual path for
me mm-hmm right
I believe that are there are no
coincidences like I've had too many
incidences where wow that's weird that
that happened right now and I believe in
those things and when they try to tie
you know mean that to the movie for me
for my brother and I cuz I remember him
and I won't cry but the end scene
because my both about of the sober as
well and we can I say that yeah okay
yeah yeah he said earlier so arm because
of that and because I thought that you
know what you tried you know it's it's
it's because he would surprised me that
they you know that you thought it was
just about the crop signs what's above
all right it wasn't enough but that's my
get now that it's personal it's a
personal thing okay and I thought and I
thought it was well shot
I thought the pacing was well done I
thought the pacing was too slow it was
just you don't like slow burns I don't
like that the next one is the village
now I like I like the relationship with
Mel Gibson just think we're getting a
call we got somebody but no I'm kidding
good I like the relationship with the
brothers uh-huh cuz that you know made
me think of you know with the brother
why you gotta be so he loves no no and I
want to back up what you're saying as
far as like you know destiny but it's a
rediscovering of faith right which Mel
you know cuz there's those creams
throughout the movie the flashbacks and
at the very end of the movie you know he
cuz of what he said he's like you know
what I'm I believe now you know
because of what he said I like that
aspect we told a good story within a a
lien invasion story right yeah yeah just
not a nine what I get it okay all right
that's okay the next one village
I really like the village do you like
the village that's I like the end I like
that his endings but you guys are
talking about the ending of the other
movie how it got to you I'm saying the
whole movie is paid off by this ending
that they're in this like you know their
own yeah yeah that also surprised me as
well yeah caught me off guard yeah yeah
copy and I like that whole thing where
price Howard is our blind yeah looking
or you know I mean that was cool that's
why they sent her yeah that was cool
yeah yeah I like know what that to was
another thing where I went you know what
dude you try to do your own style it
fits your franchise we're going okay
what's gonna be the end he starts going
we off the village already yeah there's
so many movies that you have to go then
the one that like that color I went I
wanna like it but I don't his lady in
the wall maybe in the water that's out
like it wasn't just bad yeah almost like
you went on a I don't know thing about
it is this if you're gonna like okay
let's say he didn't want to do he felt
pigeon-holed let's say he was like I've
done three movies where there's a
surprise ending and that's what people
think of me and he's like let me go to
me let me switch it up this switch the
[ __ ] yeah go completely
different guy right a black and white
twenties movie or something so we're
just like oh wow this guy can really but
if you're gonna stay in the science
sci-fi realm yeah like some weird story
it just you lost me with that and then
he goes even crazier with I think what
was right after that was the last number
ever but no happen to happening oh [ __ ]
you
Shyamalan [ __ ] you yeah
yeah yes yeah that's all yeah and you
know what and check this out okay we saw
a lady in the water yeah right and we
were like okay yeah you're gonna have a
bar you can have a bomb they can't all
be good yeah yeah yeah the one after
yeah
you can't they can't all be good you're
like okay he tried some [ __ ] yeah yeah
but then we go back to the roots I was
done
yeah he tried with that what happening
the earth is getting rid of us and then
it happens in France at the end yeah at
the end it happens in France yeah I was
yeah I go [ __ ] you don't see that a
sequel no setup to the sequel yeah let
happening yes like that's the part - it
was very sharknado yeah yeah and then
and here's where he offended he raped me
last ever now can I say something and I
wanted that to be great the casting come
on so here's the thing here we go is is
that when I was on MADtv
Jordana back Jordan Peele all right yeah
he said watch the cartoon so the arm so
I watched I went to you know watch the
and it was great that's a great little
cartoon series yeah great yeah right it
was fun fireeyes no thing you know I
love sorry I love Asian looking at Asian
you know and then when this movie came
out I couldn't believe what I was
watching
could you you know it's funny you guys
have a lot of personal connection to why
you like movies yeah I'm starting to see
that now so you don't let me just ask
you a quick one just off on this subject
yeah so when you guys watch a movie
you're not necessarily looking at like
oh I like the story of the aesthetics I
like these actresses and actors and like
you know the subject matter you you you
have to have a personal connection - no
I saw Shashi no option last night and I
have no connection to that and I cry I
love that movie no here's the thing also
you good at you going to be true the
source material I
that's what it is so it's like when I
when I Drive around town right now in LA
and I see Aquaman you know I'm not what
does it look like it I am not watching
that but blonde hair no but at the same
time though you have to remember that
when these things were first created we
were much more racist country so like of
course everybody's gonna be white and
everything that has ever made I know Dan
so you're saying though if if you really
Wayne what if Bruce Wayne was Indian
would you watch it probably depending on
you know you would throw you off the
whole you wouldn't be able to get past
the idea that he's not Indian well I
don't know it's a fictional character I
understand it but stay true that's what
that's why right when you someone like
that when the last M ever and ever and
airbender comes out you think to
yourself finally you know we get to see
it because you know alright alright let
me know we get to see us okay well let
me let me tell you the war I'm let me
show you the difference in my mind if
there's a rich billionaire and he's
Indian and he decides to be Batman I'm
fine with that
okay because because and his name is
Bruce Wayne the whole story it could be
you know whatever with the would you
change these American you know his his
plane has pre he's third-generation
Indian American and they're billionaires
he became Batman my problem while I'm
with you with this Airbender thing is he
seemed to be doing stuff that there
should be Asian people here yeah you
know you're at a monastery there rather
like a you know they're talking about
foo foo like you know Buddhist type
stuff and so then you you can't do that
you know you're I right so I'm saying if
there's a show about like you're at a
sushi restaurant and then the chef is
Indian there then I might be like well
why is that guy Indian but I see what
you're saying yeah yeah so I'm the same
problem you have a bit about that Disney
movie the Beauty and the Beast right
same thing where you they go into those
I never saw the movie but yeah they're
in a 14th century French town and
there's six random black people in this
era you can't just do that yeah it is
make me sense you're looking at you
houses how how are they there yeah so
that's what I'm saying about that's why
I'm not it's not the same to me like you
know like a Superman
if Will Smith was playing Superman yeah
like yeah there could be black people on
Krypton
like they did you just change the story
you know and trust me I don't like being
force-fed Asians either all right like
when I'm watching Star Wars
yeah I did too many I know what you're
doing there's a bit like I want like
Charlie's Angels I want these [ __ ]
white okay I don't want it but then then
why can't be white no I I get it what
I'm saying is like you're talking about
I'm talking about other subject of
force-feeding right you know a fort like
you going like okay why did you make
this person you know that guy the guy
that's playing Aquaman is so mixed race
looking that it doesn't matter we don't
know what people from Atlantis looks
like so I could knock him I'm okay with
all right I'll buy it I'm still watching
it all right why I'm just not interested
I saw the trailer he's like the second
trailer looks better
okay so Airbender okay so those are the
last we're already off the rails
casting obvious no no prepping man okay
I get the Asian element okay alright but
I want to tell you this what I was
already off for him and then he did this
and I thought okay he's gonna do
something different yeah put his
storytelling spin on it yeah so I was
already off him yeah like let's see he's
like a restaurant that I went and I got
explosive diarrhea at a restaurant right
yeah and I was like I don't know if I
want to go back here yeah and then I
went back and it's on your air bender
right yeah and I'm like I can never and
I you in your head and then here's the
thing too he did some movies that you
didn't even [ __ ] because now at this
point his name is gonna garbage yeah so
he did that movie after earth after
earth he did that with Will Smith movie
yeah that did that's the first time Will
Smith movie didn't open number one yes
yeah they didn't put his name on it but
he directed it yeah
yeah the Jaden Smith I saw huh
how was it yeah you have my iTunes right
you can watch it I bought it yeah yeah
you can watch it it was it's terrible
yeah it's not it's not a great movie but
what about the one with the elevator he
didn't direct it you know I think he
just produced he produced it I like that
one
yeah that doesn't count here's a bear
here's where he kind of came back where
the visit the visit all know the old
very movie the old
what was that called the visit the visit
the visit
I enjoyed you'd like that but I already
knew that I knew what was happening I
know but still that was his introduction
I was like okay I'm back his old way
back it's like you think oh yeah cuz he
is sort of a horror movie type guy but
he it was more psychological type of
stuff yeah but this was like a total
like you like you like you know like
when she is underneath the house and the
crawling they just they just they should
have tipped it off a way sooner than it
would have worked you know just being
like that's not your mother you know if
they attempted sooner we would have been
like it's to see already knew it was too
long yeah well it's when they go the
basement they found but still a good
movie yeah I enjoyed it it's it's a step
up of after earth yes it was an uptick
uptick yeah right and then after that I
think he did split yeah right and I
enjoyed I like lit was interesting it
was me oh so but what helped it was
McEvoy oh he's so good he's good I don't
know if anybody else they have to be
that quality actors DD but it has to be
that quality now my concern now is with
this new movie why is that emerging I
know but my concern might be that like
the story gets muddled the the lore gets
messed with you know like they don't
explain enough of what's happened in 25
years yeah you know I I don't know yeah
but you know what um we don't know yet
but I'm gonna won't know yeah I'll watch
it they don't know yeah I'm gonna walk
well watch it together I knew not to
watch lady in the water in the theaters
we should do a movie review show
yeah I think we should do it once a
month we build up a bank and then we
just watch it but I'm gonna say this is
the movie the worst movie in the last 10
years though what do you think it is
like a movie that was so hyped up okay
it was a cultural movie that just was
the worst and I have I know what it is
the last Jedi no no actually I have one
worse than that what solo was way worse
that was because could I say no it was
way worse hockey how you gonna get a guy
who looks like he's older than Harrison
Ford was I agree you know he looks like
Harris before his father he's just not a
good looking he's he how can I say this
though mmm he did try it just wasn't a
good movie yeah and then Donald Glover
uh-huh he was a good Lando yeah I
thought he had the cadence right is that
Kathleen Kennedy it'sit's Kathleen
Kennedy pretty thing yeah I just I
thought I thought that this is like they
they broke the stigma that did alors
they're like yeah you know I mean that
that thing you have that you know they
should just leave it alone just don't do
anything no more no more
no no no no more no more I'm like we're
done with it
nobody deal with Luke dude come on man
this is Luke Skywalker you can't just
have him on this remote island and then
have him and then it didn't show any of
the training that he did you know how
she learning these intricate Jedi
lightsaber moves on her own now you know
what I'm saying it's like dude sure dude
second worst in Empire Strikes Back
it shows Yoda actually training Luke you
know with the all that stuff yeah but
what was the one when they went it's
just the one where they went to the
casino yes oh that was they didn't even
need to do that yeah the hall yeah
no wart no the worst part the worst part
when I almost stood up and I almost
turned to the crowd I go I'm done right
was when Princess Leia is in space dead
oh yeah right she's dead right uh-huh
and you go she opens her eyes she's a
Jedi that's not that's the explanation
I know but can I say something I don't
know no no but the thing is is this okay
let's say Superman
let's see see see a Superman movie right
and all of a sudden a guy charges
Superman mm-hm and he pulls out a sword
out of his hand right and slices the man
and then he has porcupine skin mm-hmm
and kills another man in your head you'd
be like that's not what Wolverine does
oh I gave you saying I know you can't
make up [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah just
yeah if you have ruled out default it's
like a vampire
break some rule that's not what they do
yeah I get you right because then we can
make even though we've never seen Jedi's
in space so how would we know it's
because the thing is is that Princess
Leia specifically Princess Leia
specifically has never shown any but we
don't know what's happened in 30 years
I've only seen her telepathy because you
know how like yeah we know about me tell
you when we tell you when I was out well
I was out when she was she put on a
dress like she changed clothes like she
just found out our son killed her
husband her ex-husband now you know
watch movie a talking about this is the
other movie there's a lot of pretty bad
Princess Leia stuff this is the first
one before that oh well would I forgot
that what that one was called that was
called um force awaken force awake yeah
I was thinking I was done on force
awakened when you know they find out -
he just haunts almost dead and they the
next scene she got a hair and makeup a
new dress on yeah I was like I'm out
this [ __ ] went to the [ __ ] beauty
salon yeah like I'm like this this is
like I'm sorry you can't
there's things like that that I can't
accurately get past okay before so again
the same scene right huh huh solid eyes
right right they cut to Chewbacca he
goes best friend I better see your face
your hairy face in tears like just wet
like oh look a dog that went into a
swimming pool like what the [ __ ] I don't
even give me stops leaves you is that
movie was worse than than last year
another thing is worse
no I just saw I just saw force awakens
again watch the last Jenna hi barb I
have something same with Jedi
specifically Jedi's yeah there's a
hierarchy when you say you start as a
paddle on this you know schooling right
like like belts like yellow belt you
know what I mean - your second I love
but now everyone knows how to do that
stuff that's from force awaken that's a
Jedi that's true man that is true Jedi
weapon man you know the best the best
point about this is my force I love him
I love his care you made a point he's
not a Jedi did you made this point and I
and I was like god damn - should we make
the movie but that scene where where the
the lightsabers in the thing okay so
what you're saying is then what you're
saying is this okay I pick toward the
end of force away yes she's riding wheel
around right and they're in the forum
they're in the forest go with a little
Asian lady with the glasses
your mom's great in it right my mom
right the woman that creature lives
there my mom yeah right so they're in
the forest right okay so okay so what
you're saying is is that she loses a
lifesaver uh-huh
you know this what you what should have
happened was the lightsaber passes her
and then Luke is the
that's what the [ __ ] should have
happened because like at the end of the
movie when you go in it's Luke who cares
that scene toon would have created an
uproar in the movie standing ovations
yeah yeah that was so interesting that
it would be so because you haven't seen
him through the whole movie
she should not have been able to like
all of a sudden she got Jedi power yeah
there's a Jedi Academy yeah a Padawan I
have to start it's good to go to a
planet in a jungle to learn I agree with
that she's all of a sudden like okay
what they did to Luke's character's
disrespectful man you can't just like
him right I don't mind him being like
like really realizing that the Jedi's
have problems and he may die I'm fine
with that but what I'm telling you is
force awakens is worse can I go to mine
okay go ahead but so you're saying now
you're saying now in 30 years they
haven't upgraded the the Death Star so
you mean so now the whole horror Star
Wars and Return of the Jedi the movie is
all centered around a huge plan to blow
up this high-tech not technological a
machine right so now they sneak in the
back door okay Wow they sneak in the
back door just to be a high-level
captain walking around the back door she
goes to a random terminal and takes the
shields down you mean to tell me nobody
in Mission Control could be like yo uh
the shields are down put them back up
this is a Death Star just a [ __ ]
digit are like so once again the Death
Star has bad security I didn't agree I
agree with them but he's right that's
what made it worse okay I mean that when
they blew up another Death Star I was
like really and this one by the way this
one can drains energy from the Sun yeah
if you drain energy from the Sun
everything dies you don't need to blow
up the planet right
they're dead it's just overkill what a
waste of energy
stupid technology unbelievably your
knowledge can I tell you why though
mm-hmm
the last Jedi is the worst okay because
the first three movies right you know a
new hope I mean the free ones yes the
ones that we saw
we're not counted as a kid no no I said
the first three mm-hmm it's it's
basically the Luke Skywalker's voyage
yeah right we see him so miss humble
beginning we realize is actually Darth
Vader's voyage but I guess right right
but we see this kid humble beginnings
right
he's a kid he doesn't know his dreams
yeah there's no power he's a regular guy
rocket burns with crisp yeah like you
know better we needed to happen for him
to leave yeah that would there's no
Disney [ __ ] they're [ __ ] brutal yeah
moon being a scholar in the 70s I know
you see these burnt crisp I know people
know that's uncle Owen yeah right and
you're like oh as a kid you're like holy
[ __ ] this is real
yeah they're not [ __ ] around right so
we get to the last Jedi okay we should
finally see the guy that hooked us into
the movies in the first place our hero
right right it's not him
I know but it's also 30 years later no
it's not even that just look at this
okay what do you mean it's not him just
listen okay this is that in Return of
the Jedi what is the one thing he wanted
to do to Darth Vader turn him good right
uh-huh that's who he is right
Darth Vader is the worst thing to happen
in that world right he's the most evil
guy aside from the Emperor robbers more
evil yeah he is more evil evil body
manipulated he's still second command
don't they get it
right he's evil right he's just out fine
but Luke Skywalker's like I can still
turn him yeah yeah yeah but then he he
wants to
slaughter his nephew that's not him
I know what you're saying that's not him
but he didn't that's not her
he did he did try to if he had into
flashback he did when he was in the
school I know but if he'd wanted to do
it all again he's like look at all the
review that has been killed
I'm just saying is he never saw like
imagine if you had like Jedi power you
could see the future and you see that if
you let me believe it doesn't matter
because we will kill everyone in the
book said that darth vader's you got to
kill Darth Vader and he's just like nah
when eternal heat that's not who Luke is
his character I get it
the other moves still working and I'm
gonna just say if you're listening a
Disney and Kathleen Kennedy or anyone
that involved in Star Wars okay JJ
Abrams okay I know they might not be huh
but I'm just saying this you know in
hope I'm hoping well there's drinking
another one I know but this is what I
want yeah I don't think they are don't
we they have to the story's not dumb no
they have done because that didn't go on
the last year they was such a debacle
there's no way now they're gonna maybe
they could just reboot but if you reboot
this is what you need to do do you ever
see Ken Burns Vietnam documentary you
never did I don't see now okay you know
who Ken Burns we have it on Netflix oh
yeah some people yeah he made the
documentary and then you know what he
did he didn't release it what he did was
he played the documentary for two years
in front of Vietnam vets the other side
of Vietnam Vietnamese soldiers I agree
any so give me not give me notes okay
give me no all the Star Wars geeks right
right so get about a hundred of the most
die-hard Star Wars geeks right and go
this is you know don't even film the
show do it in storyboard yeah right and
go this is where we're headed
notes get the notes I agree put it on a
table it's that important yeah I agree
and go yeah we can't cause we can't we
can't have Princess Leia in the space it
doesn't make any sense because we can't
have that in our head Ryan cuz now I
want to remove it and you can't but they
gave that director from the last Jedi
all
who is the director what's his name his
name is um what's his name can you fight
his name ryan Johnson and his whole
thing was I want to surprise everybody
that I would look through the lightsaber
over shoulder that was supposed to be
like a surprise
[ __ ] Iran Johnson yeah [ __ ] you they
drop the ball they drop the ball big
time hey what the [ __ ] I don't know what
time is it how long were we out here oh
[ __ ] okay what what done I'm sick now
7:49
yeah we guys know we're good I was sick
I wasn't even gonna come but I'm like if
you didn't show up you I'm glad you
showed it cuz you know you and I if you
oh my god yeah you you need to work on
your communication skills you need to
take your hairy knuckles out of my
[ __ ] face right now all right good -
steak knives - yeah that's why I came I
was like barely getting here I
appreciate you sweating like I'm
delirious mm-hmm and I'm like I gotta
show up for Eric now you have to and I
appreciate that but why do you do what
out here in the [ __ ] countryside no
it's just because I don't have listen I
don't have a sweet setup like Tiger
belly you know what I mean and it's TV
week I don't have a corner in a dungeon
I don't have a dungeon corner yeah so
you know I'm getting there you know yeah
I'm gonna I just but this is less
comfortable I also I just announced it I
might add all things comedy so I'm gonna
do a few here all things comedy just let
me you know I'm in the family so you
sure you are and yeah when did you do
that
did you be started yeah no no no no
actually oh this this episode hasn't
aired yet but it will air by the time
this one comes out yeah but I
interviewed Blake from workaholics yeah
here here I have brought him here for
that yeah so I said you know so I'll do
some guests yeah yeah and it's just
comfortable I don't got to worry about
all this stuff and what I love about all
things comedy is is that it has repeat
the people on top our friends
yeah like Gelber and all those bill and
now Madrigal Ari Shaffir born Bert
Kreischer Tom and they're all our
friends right so it's like and also they
don't um take any money from you yeah
it's a great partnership yeah it's a
good partnership and um they've only
been you know straight up and helpful
and that's well that's why I'm here man
yeah you know I like I say I felt like I
was late to the party I've been on your
thing twice I've been on yours three
times yeah so here I am
it was a question for me I was gonna
yeah I like you guys like you know you
guys are obviously really my favorite
leaves one in two I'm gonna say who's
number one though God am i one can I
tell you why I'm one I'm I can't tell
you I am I'll tell you why I'm lying 1a
1b you know I know what you know what
Steve can be number one you know what
I'll tell you why this is why I love ste
is I have a lot of affection for you
know it not only do I have a question
for you but can I say this about how he
is so much affection for you I literally
when you came to LA 15 years ago I had
dread I could this [ __ ] guy's gonna
die out here
I'll smoking pot every day they have the
skills and there's no skills I try to
get a jobs
I got on my job at the Tempe improv I go
to my job I love these because I'll tell
you why Eric Griffin Eric Griffin's
audience doesn't know yeah alright it's
your honor so I got him a job at the
Tempe improv three days later four days
later I'm sorry
four days later Bob I got fired I go why
I tried to attack somebody you try to
attack a waiter no can I tell the proper
story yeah I was a food runner there
uh-huh
and so my job I had to like carry super
nachos and yeah whatever they ordered in
between the shows right in the dark so
you had him like you know I mean like
but but like with like everyone else had
to do that - yeah it's not like you had
all
specifically blonde girl I forgot her
name she put her order wrong
no green onions or something oh you are
attacking a female no no no let me
explain myself man
so I like so I like they set the scent
to order back and then they were
complaining and then all I did was I
went up to her lets her name was Britney
I don't know if her name was Britney I
just hey Britney next time can you make
sure on the computer not just to put no
green onions and she goes is that right
oh like that that's what she did yeah no
what do you do well I didn't though
backstory she was dating the manager why
are you whispering yeah she was there
she was dating the manager so at the end
of my shift he goes yeah yeah I'll tell
you what exactly what can I tell you why
that can I tell you why they didn't
happen that I did it happened is because
unfortunately for you Steve
unfortunately for you is is that
who else managed the Tempe improv Adam
Egan I'm not gonna tell you I'm totally
for you Ryan warned me about this I know
that did not know about Adam I know but
I'm an Adam works at The Comedy Store
he's the Manager he was the Comedy Store
yeah this can be improved my friend he
managed it can be improv well I worked
there no but look at this okay the first
thing out of his mouth when I met him
years ago was your brother man he tried
to assault somebody so what I'm saying
to you is is that I can hear it from you
but I know you and I wasn't there so you
can twist it the way you want to twist
it but I'm gonna lean more toward the
centre of it the middle where it wasn't
as it wasn't that there was some
screaming for on your part no see now
from from hearing the other story about
the movie theater yeah I think it like
see Steve's very principled okay right
so there was something about I there was
a minute when he said she was like oh
whatever she did yeah
that wasn't a prank that was the moment
he would I get it right let's take a
break guys I know I believe the green
onions yeah I believe the super nachos
that's what I'm saying
right I believe she went oh really right
right but what I don't believe is it
ended there oh right that there was
something that she had said after her
attitude that put him in the red zone
and then that's what got him fired can
you admit to me that because I'm going
to tell you another thing
here's another words it appears another
two words I can say to you do you just
had a great realization about yourself
if this is a court case right I could
also bring up two other names sushi Dan
this is definitely breaking get him a
job again on my job at sushi Dan right
two days later he gets fired why he
talked to the sushi head sushi chef
inappropriately so I'm going to say
something right now all right I mean I
want to defend this is what what did he
say to you there's some falseness going
on okay all right okay I'm uh I worked
the noon shift and I'm a food runner
again here's what we know you're not and
so I took a order with the sushi orders
you have to get it directly from the
sushi chef then he'll go okay Table
three table eight tables or whatever
uh-huh so this this Kareem dude from
Salt whatever he was like yeah he WA
table you three talking to me like I'm
in the military like I'm like the rookie
in the you know I'm saying and so I went
up to him and I go hey man you can't
talk to me like I just about to say
Steve in these three examples there's a
moment where you feel disrespected yeah
and you react right yeah okay
and so no I go hey man you can't talk to
me like that yeah we're not in Korea
dude lean on me now is there a moment
that you could say to yourself though
that you are being disrespected and you
were in a unit and the right but is
there a moment that you could say to
yourself if I had to handle it
differently I would have you know what I
mean
but you would take him aside after work
and be like it right earlier today right
I you know in through counseling now and
through my therapy I would handle see
I'm personal growth right here yeah I
know but what I was going to be you show
it's great to show like people who have
learned don't react like I did you'll
get fired you'll get fired
oh no no can I defend myself again no go
ahead the manager was this Korean lady
and I've smoked cigarettes back then and
I was smoking cigarettes like in the
front mm-hmm and she in the way she
talked to me was the same kind of Korean
vibe like you go tombé you you know you
have to go you know and she was the way
her tone it was the tone dude okay so
you know what I mean no now given what
we've said uh-huh to where he is now
uh-huh I never thought because he's got
the ste BBB show thank you right it's
doing okay pretty good right good great
great right people know it yeah when I
go on the road where Stevie we be here
yeah yeah yeah all right number two is
is that he has a girlfriend which is a
miracle straight from the heavens right
wait wait
none of us should be talking about no
it's a miracle specially especially he
he's he sings in a band yeah yeah doing
well and he made oh we made a pilot on
worst fireteam yeah yeah he is hilarious
you're gonna be jealous is it good it's
fine was the sketches or almost gone if
it's [ __ ] nobody didn't almost get
more pissed yeah I thought Craig was
gonna work on this he can't even wanna
do it though you need to I'm going to be
here baby I know three movies a train
Craig I'm going to he just hasn't
that would be gold yeah yeah I'm
bringing cracking we really should
though this into a movie thing we will I
would like to do that let's just do it I
would love to do a movie review huh cuz
I have my own opinion you know me too we
can move oh dude we'll do it one the
ones on Netflix because I've been
rewatching movies from like the 80s by
the way I love watching the Netflix
movies because I watch Teen Wolf I like
to bright
I enjoyed bright good Will Smith one
yeah but I wouldn't have watched it in
the theaters well I would have watched
it in the future I love all that dragon
not that kind of [ __ ] yeah let's go
nostalgic will you go 80's 90's out so
we're gonna review what we'll do is
we'll watch it we'll have a Netflix
movie that we'll watch review yeah a
couple in the theater we'll talk about
someone from the half notes yeah
sure knows well guys I think that's a
good stopping point that was a good one
these are two of my favorite people in
the whole wide world
I want to thank Stevie Wiebe Steve Lee
for coming in and one of my best friends
in the whole wide world who I love
dearly Bobby Lee
the Lee brothers and thank you for
coming on Griffin
[Music]
[Applause]